Donnerstag in einer Sitzungswoche ich
begrüße Sie ganz herzlich aus dem
Deutschen Bundestag die Parlamentarier
haben heute wieder ein Picke packe
volles Programm und wie sie das gewohnt
sind können Sie das ganze hier bei
Phoenix live verfolgen es geht natürlich
um Energie um Gas etc es geht um den
Ukraine Krieg aber gleich zu Beginn
beschäftigen sich die Abgeordneten hier
mit einem sehr wichtigen Thema nämlich
mit der digitalstrategie der
Bundesregierung die deutsche Wirtschaft
leidet nicht nur unter den hohen
Energiepreisen sondern auch unter der
fehlenden Digitalisierung in der größten
Volkswirtschaft in Europa so haben nur
6,3% der deutschen Haushalte einen
Glasfaseranschluss im internationalen
Vergleich ist das nur Platz 78 vorne
liegen die Arabischen Emirate mit fast
97% gefolgt von Singapur 95,8 und China
94,9%. der europäische Index für
digitale Wirtschaft und Gesellschaft da
rangiert Deutschland nur auf Platz 13
und bei der Durchdringung der
Wirtschaftsunternehmen mit digital da
liegt Deutschland nur auf Platz 16 da
muss also einiges passieren und der
zuständige digitalminister und
Verkehrsminister Volker Wissing hat die
digitalstrategie in Meseberg bei der
Klausur vorgestellt und heute beraten
also die Abgeordneten und das will ich
auch tun mit meinen beiden Gästen ich
begrüße ganz herzlich Carina Konrad
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende
der FDP und Nadine schön in der gleichen
Funktion für die cdu/csu
Frau Konrad guten Morgen bevor wir über
die Inhalte quasi reden zunächst mal zur
Struktur also ich war schon ein bisschen
überrascht als die Ampel sich gebildet
hat das ist kein eigenes
digitalministerium vielleicht mit
Bildung gibt das war gerade von vielen
fdp-politikern immer gefordert worden
selbst aus der Union gab es diese
Stimmen und die Union hat heute einen
eigenen Antrag vorgelegt der fordert sie
das auch das Problem ist ja dass eben in
den vergangenen Legislaturperioden
dieses Thema immer so ein bisschen
aufgesplittet war keiner wusste wer
dafür zuständig ist jetzt hat also der
Verkehrsminister nach wie vor den Hut
auf das war in der vergangenen Regierung
auch so und hat wieder viele Dinge
wegdelegiert das ist doch wieder eine
Zersplitterung nein es ist genau der ist
umgekehrte der digitalminister hat jetzt
den Hut auf das haben Sie richtig gesagt
und der große Erfolg der ja auch sich
hinter dieser digitalstrategie verbirgt
ist das jetzt alle Ressorts auch
zuliefern und sich verbindliche Ziele
geben und darüber tatsächlich dann auch
als oder man kann es auch sagen darunter
als Fundament das gebaut wird was
notwendig ist in Deutschland um
tatsächlich Digitalisierung wirklich
voranzubringen und sich nicht immer nur
im kleinen klein zu verlieren und den
Stillstand zu verwalten wie das in der
Vergangenheit war ist dass man mit drei
hebelprojekten wirklich auch die
Grundlage dafür setzt das jetzt
Digitalisierung auch in der Fläche
ausgerollt wird und auch so dass die
Menschen das merken und spürbare
Verbesserung merken und das vor allen
Dingen auch sie haben es gerade erwähnt
die Unternehmen eine spürbare
Verbesserung merken wir haben diese
Krise und gerade weil wir im Moment die
Krisen haben ist es umso wichtiger
tatsächlich jetzt in Deutschland zu
modernisieren um dann auch mit Schwung
noch mal nach vorne schauen zu können
noch mal ganz kurz zurückgeschaut mit
Ihnen Frau schön wenn schließlich hat
die CDU CSU 16 Jahre die Bundeskanzlerin
gestellt es wurde Überflug Taxi
spekuliert etc und am Schluss kam
reichlich wenig raus ich habe die
bitteren Zahlen eben vorgelesen was ist
da schief gelaufen war es nur die
Organisation oder ist das so ein
orchideen-thema dass man einfach dann
gerne auch mal links liegen lässt es
wurden nicht nur über flugtaxis
spekuliert es gibt jetzt flugtaxen also
ich wundere mich auch dass der
Verkehrsminister sich so lustig macht
die ganze Zeit über das Thema aber um
auf Ihre Frage zu antworten wir haben in
der Vergangenheit gesehen dass es mehr
Koordinierung braucht bei der
digitalpolitik wir hatten das in der
letzten Legislaturperiode aus dem
Kanzleramt heraus gemacht eine Steuerung
über alle Ressorts hinweg und die
Erkenntnis war dass wir das noch mit
mehr unterfüttern müssen dass es ein
eigenes digitalministerium braucht was
eine Steuerungsfunktion hat was
Mitarbeiter hat die diese Koordinierung
machen können und das auch immer der
Wunsch der FDP was haben sie jetzt
gemacht sie haben das noch mal zurück
gegliedert in die ressortstruktur haben
nur den Namen getauscht beim
Verkehrsminister der heißt jetzt
Minister für digitales und Verkehr und
der hat aber nicht mehr Kompetenzen als
frühere Minister und er sagt auch selbst
also die digitalstrategie liegt jetzt da
ab sofort ist jedes Haus dafür
verantwortlich dass die Projekte
umgesetzt werden wir finden in dieser
Strategie keine messbaren Ziele ganz
wenige wir finden keine klare Steuerung
kein Monitoring und es wird mehr oder
weniger dem Zufall überlassen wie sich
das in den nächsten Jahren
weiterentwickelt da muss ich sagen da
ist aus den der Vergangenheit nicht
gelernt worden im Gegenteil es ein
Rückschritt Frau Konrad der Minister hat
Ziele definiert bis 2025 und dann die
Endziele quasi bis zum Jahre 20 30 er
hat 18 Leuchtturm Projekte benannt zum
Beispiel die Glasfaserverkabelung 50%
bis zum Jahr 2025 da sagen viele das ist
wenig ambitioniert allerdings bevor wir
ins kleinere gehen gucken wir mal aufs
große eine der Hauptkritikpunkte ist ja
es steht überhaupt nichts über Geld da
drin und das ist natürlich hochsensibel
in der Zeit jetzt wo wir sehen dass es
an allen Ecken und Enden fehlt muss man
doch Sorge tragen dass diese Projekte
niemals mit Leben erfüllt werden können
also erstmal will ich schon bin ich froh
dass es klargestellt natürlich sind klar
definierte Ziele drin wenn man sich
selbst Jahreszahlen gibt als
Bundesregierung finde ich das als
Abgeordneter schon mal in ziemlich guten
Richtwert dafür dass wir nachher auch
genau schauen können wie schnell jetzt
die Ressorts umsetzen und natürlich
hängt auch alles mit Geld zusammen und
in den Ressorts gibt es ja jeweils auch
digital Budgets für die einzelnen
Maßnahmen aber was wichtig ist und das
will ich auch noch mal betonen an der
Stelle ist tatsächlich dass man sie
Grundlage jetzt endlich mal schafft man
kann viel über Kleinklein reden und das
wurde auch in der Vergangenheit viel
getan aber wenn man wirklich einen
Nutzen für die Unternehmen für die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger in diesem Land
haben will dann muss man auch das
Fundament bauen dafür dass
Digitalisierung überhaupt in der Fläche
notwendig ist wir haben bis heute keine
digitalen IDs wir haben bis heute zu
wenig
Glasfaser in der Flasche wir haben zu
wenig 5g-anschlüsse und Ausbau und der
Fläche und auch ist immer
Vereinheitlichung Standards bei Daten
damit auch ein weltweiter in Europa
weiter austauscht stattfinden kann ist
ganz zentral dafür dass auch wirklich
ein messbarer Mehrwert nachher da ist
und das sind Dinge die jetzt auch
vehement angegangen werden und
ehrlicherweise die auch lange schon
hätten erledigt sein können wir haben ja
da gar kein Lizenz deshalb wundert mich
das auch dass dann einfach immer nur
gemeckert wird was könnte noch besser
noch mehr noch schneller sein das ist
auch die Aufgabe der Opposition ganz
eindeutig aber wir müssen tatsächlich
auch an einem Strang ziehen erkennen
dass das hier jetzt wirklich ein
zentrales Projekt ist um Deutschland
auch nur zu modernisieren und diesen
Stillstand zu beenden da hat man es
einfacher in der Opposition Kritik ist
da ja quasi eingepreist Frau schön Peter
Altmaier hat sehr häufig gesagt ich
traue mich überhaupt nicht und ich mache
das auch nicht mehr aus Autos oder Zügen
meine Ministerkollegen in Europa oder
woanders anzurufen das ist ja peinlich
weil wir nach wie vor natürlich in
Deutschland wirklich eine also gerade im
Telefonbereich eine ein System haben was
wirklich
geht hinten liegt sage ich mal
vorsichtig auch da hat ja die zuständige
haben die zuständigen Minister der Union
ja nicht absichtlich versagt sondern das
liegt natürlich auch an einem Punkt der
dir klar diskutiert werden muss den hat
er bisschen ja auch benannt da geht es
nämlich um die Kompetenzstreitigkeiten
zwischen Kommunen Ländern und Bund also
mal eben da überall solche Telefonmasten
hochzuziehen 5g mal eben an der Seite
von Bahnstrecken zu installieren hört
sich gut an funktioniert aber deswegen
nicht haben sie eine Lösung wie man das
ändern kann
ja in der gigabit-strategie sind ja
Lösungen drin und die setzen auch auf
dem auf was wir vorbereitet haben wir
haben in der letzten Legislaturperiode
einen Telekommunikationsgesetz neu
geschaffen was es zum Beispiel
ermöglicht in den Häusern die inhouse
Verkabelung also wirklich das Glasfaser
bis ins Haus zu erleichtern da müsstet
die Regierung jetzt ansetzen und
weitermachen wir haben bei
mobilfunkausbau bei der letzten Auktion
als Parlament darauf gedrängt dass die
versorgungsauflagen stärker werden das
erwarte ich jetzt natürlich auch bei der
nächsten Auktion und vor allem dürfen
wir nicht nur Auflagen machen sondern
die Bundesnetzagentur muss das auch noch
strenger Monitoren strenger
kontrollieren selbst Messungen machen
denn dass die gefühlte der gefühlte
Ausbau ist nicht der gleiche wie die
Mobilfunkunternehmen sagen was er
ausgebaut haben auch in den Rankings wir
sind gut vorangekommen aber die Bedarfe
werden eben auch größer wir brauchen
heute viel mehr Datenmengen als wir es
noch vor wenigen Jahren gebraucht werden
und deshalb muss auch da Wachstum
genauso mitgehen da sind wir auf einem
guten Weg in der Anhörung wurde auch
gesagt im Prinzip ist sind die Ziele die
da jetzt drin stehen ist das was alles
schon vorbereitet war also wenn da jetzt
wirklich eine Schippe draufgelegt werden
soll dann braucht es eben auch konkrete
Maßnahmen da hat der Minister auch zwei
drei vorgeschlagen leider hat das sie
teilweise wieder einkassiert wie zum
Beispiel den Fond von dem wir gar nicht
wissen ob er kommt oder ob er nicht
kommt Glasfaserkabel ist das Stichwort
8,1 Millionen Haushalte da liegt das
Glasfaserkabel an aber nur 3 muss ich
selber mal gucken 3,8 Millionen
Haushalte haben bisher einen Vertrag
abgeschlossen 12 Millionen Leitungen
liegen in der Nähe und der Rest ist
Schweigen wir haben über 40 Millionen
Haushalte man hat ausgerechnet wenn man
das Glasfaserkabel so verlegt wie es
vorgesehen ist nämlich mit 60 cm tiefer
tiefbauweise dann wird das ewig dauern
in Deutschland Glasfaserkabel komplett
hat deswegen gibt es ja jetzt diese
ritzmethode dass man den Asphalt nur
anritzt da sagen jetzt aber die Kommunen
schon das ist gefährlich da gibt es
Schäden und jetzt wird schon als erstes
wieder über einen Fonds berichtet den
der Minister plant das kostet alles ein
wahnsinniges Geld und wie geht's
schneller
schön auch die Problematik die
Widersprüche aufgezählt auf der einen
Seite sagt natürlich jeder er will das
haben aber wenn dann die Baumaßnahme vor
der eigenen Haustür stattfindet in der
eigenen Kommune gab es ja oft immer
Widerstände ich glaube schon dass ich
dieser Geist geändert hat vor allen
Dingen weil sich dieser Geist auch
mittlerweile in der Politik insgesamt
geändert hat wir haben in der letzten
Legislaturperiode noch vernommen dass
man 5g eben nicht an jeder Milch keine
bräuchte ich glaube mittlerweile gibt es
doch Einigkeit darüber dass man das
braucht und dass wir um Deutschland zu
modernisieren auf voran kommen muss und
das hängt auch ganz viel damit zusammen
wie schnell sollte Dinge gehen und
welche Verfahren angewendet werden wie
Ausschreibungen designt werden da gab es
in der Vergangenheit glaube ich auch
Erkenntnisse die in der Zukunft zu
Verbesserungen führen können wenn man
gerade darüber redet welche Methoden
werden angewendet aber auch wie designt
man den Ausschreibungen überhaupt damit
man auch schneller vorkommt weil am Ende
muss das Kabel gelegt werden dafür
braucht es auch Menschen die das machen
dafür braucht es aber auch die
Bereitschaft von Kommunen das mit
umsetzen zu wollen und wenn ich bei mir
so ein Wahlkreis unterwegs bin sehe ich
überall Schilder wo tatsächlich im
Moment auch dafür geworben wird und
angekündigt wird das Glasfaser jetzt
auch in in die Fläche kommt und dass wir
da jetzt noch schneller werden und auch
im ausschreibungsdesign auch im
förderdesign so vorgehen dass die
unterversorgten Flächen dann auch
versorgt werden das ist ein großer
Gewinn und das haben wir halt auch jetzt
fest vor Frau schön was kann Berlin von
Schleswig-Holstein lernen
Schleswig-Holstein hat 61%
Glasfaserkabel Anliegen Berlin nur 10
und Berlin hat auch den traurigen
letzten Platz in der 5g Technik was
läuft der falsch na es kommt sehr darauf
an wie das vor Ort umgesetzt wird im
Saarland haben wir für das ganze Land
eine zentrale Ausschreibung gemacht und
da läuft der Ausbau der
Glasfaseranbindung in jedes Haus
flächendeckend weil die Landesregierung
sich zentral dem Thema angenommen hat
das ist ein anderen Ländern leider nicht
so da können wir als Bund auch nur
bedingt was machen aber was wir eben
machen können sind die Rahmenbedingungen
machen und Frau Konrad hat jetzt eben
auf Ihre Frage nicht geantwortet was
nämlich zum Beispiel mit diesem vor ist
der dazu dienen soll wenn man diese
Alternativen verlegemethoden macht also
nur das trenching-verfahren
Bordstein und es passiert was es gibt ja
die Straße geht kaputt dann hat der
Minister angekündigt einen vorzuschaffen
um diese Schäden dann aus diesem vor
heraus zu bezahlen mittlerweile ist in
der Strategie nur noch ein Prüfauftrag
und es gibt auch Streit darüber wer
diesen Form bezahlen soll es gibt noch
kein Konzept ich weiß nicht ob er kommt
deswegen teile ich ja alle Ziele und
sehe auch die Bedarfe aber ich sehe noch
nicht dass das was in der
gigabit-strategie drin steht die jetzt
ein halbes Jahr alt ist dass die Themen
auch progressiv angegangen werden und
warum ist das alles so wichtig also die
deutschen Industrieunternehmen nur zu
auf Platz 16 in Europa was die
Verkabelung zum Beispiel angeht ist
digitale da hat der Minister gesagt wir
müssen mindestens zu Platz 10 kommen und
jeder Bürger merkt es ja täglich also
wenn man personalauspreis braucht dann
Führerschein das dauert alles ewig
selbst die Ukrainer die zu uns kommen
Lächeln darüber bei denen lief es viel
besser also gerade auch in dem Bereich
der Verwaltung warum schafft es
Deutschland nicht den also nahe Ausweis
endlich einzuführen und in ein Handy zu
integrieren ja das ist eine Frage die
habe ich mir auch gestellt als als wir
in dieser Legislaturperiode
zusammengekommen sind dann auch
Koalitionsverhandlungen geführt haben
und die haben wir uns ehrlicherweise
alle zusammengestellt als Ampelkoalition
und deshalb wird es da jetzt auch so
kommen dass wir diese digitale
Identitäten schaffen die die
Voraussetzungen sind dafür dass all dass
man den Führerschein digitalisiert hat
dass man seinen Pass digitalisiert dass
man auf sein kurbelt Zertifikat
beispielsweise digitalisiert hat und
vieles vieles mehr dass sie
Voraussetzungen dafür dass wir auch in
der Digitalisierung der Verwaltung
Vorankommen weil Digitalisierung das ist
mehr als als ein Blatt Papier zu einer
PDF einzuscannen und und irgendwo
abzulegen digital sondern ist es
tatsächlich auch das Bürgerinnen und
Bürger in ihrem Alltag Vereinfachungen
haben und das ist auch spürbar ist für
Unternehmen gerade bei
gewerbesteueranmeldungen bei vielen
Dingen die Unternehmen heute wahnsinnig
belasten bürokratisch in ihrem Alltag
das ist da auch zu spürbaren
Vereinfachungen kommt damit unser
Unternehmensstandort auch nachhaltig und
wettbewerbsfähig ist klingt immer gut
wenn es die reale Umsetzung geht dann
dauert das ewig ich höre die Klingel sie
müssen